Ah ah ah
[music]
Amazing tonkatsu You can make tonkatsu at home Well, it
takes a lot of work, but fried food has calories
This is what I'm talking about, but when I said the post village for turnips,
I left that drying -- well, you can't take over, right?
It's
okay, but I didn't have a rice cooker in my house, but I had a
clay pot, so I cooked it with a clay pot.
It's
delicious, but it's delicious, but this pork cutlet has 6 types.
It's a juicy pork cutlet when it's being beaten at a high temperature, and it's quite a bit of a
curve.
I don't know why, but I'm saying that I have a longing for tonkatsu,
but this tonkatsu sauce is also delicious.
Oops
, I thought it was just for the handing over that my husband gave me
[Music]
Bride's Home Cooking